yeah so let's have a quick recap of what
we did last time just so you can ask
questions we had labor covering our
favorite we have small things to the
left large labels to the right we have
projections we want to do three set with
perfect completeness so then we pick
some probability distribution we pick
the X and wild random and then we set Z
according to this so if X was false we
would make sure that one of these were
true and otherwise we would sort of make
zio I like what is wrong right and then
it turns out compared to previously when
we didn't have this for certain we've
got much worse correlations between y
and z so that sort of made there are two
ways to get around this either you to
repeat the random bias parameter which
sort of has been used once more well I
use this to make a commercial for myself
okay
um
but the only resort after what I've done
in this lecture the only thing I'm over
aren t 3 which predicates our
approximation assistant is a max not to
predicate this is the one that's true if
and only if they are not to two literals
so this was known from a long time ago
that it was more hard to approximate
between five within 5 8 plus epsilon
five-eighths is the random ratio and in
fact this is true also for satisfiable
instances remembered need some more
technicians are not in fact I need to
combine these two ideas to make that
proof lie so this was a naproxen a year
and a half ago so the thing to the more
important technique that's been used
lots of times is to have the smooth
label cover and the smooth label cover
is the property that if you take any two
labels in any set here the probability
of a random neighbor that I project on
to something is small and you can make
this as orbit early as small as you want
and that's sort of an important if
you're ever going to work with label
covers have smooth label covers in mind
because they might turn out to make life
easier and they exist okay anything we
just did yes the smooth right so what
you have to do is you have to avoid so
here we are avoiding in fact if you look
at the assignments or three bits we're
avoiding two of the date okay so you
need to avoid one more okay and this in
particular means that why can't any more
be independent of X so that doesn't so
either Y or Z has to be dependent X if
you're going to just have the
distribution on on the max to predicate
and that sort of creates additional
complications that you have yeah there
are more things to worry about since you
now have a correlation also between x
and y its source
that paper also has a world record in so
one thing you can have noticed is that
I've got fairly good dependence on the
epsilon and Delta C in the max tool in
and it got much worse in this max 2sat
or in the max reset and in the max bak
to it gets horrendously words so I moved
from a polynomial polynomial in next
tool in to sort of exponential
dependence in max 3sat and in max not to
their sort of a tower of Exponential's
that's on the height of 1 over epsilon
in the constants so it gets worse yeah
but importing a smooth label cover and
once we did that for three set it wasn't
too hard because mod early if you sort
of accept it with seven eight plus
epsilon hear you had some calculations
and then you could prove that the sum of
this type where alpha was a subset of
beta and beta were moderately small was
large and then we got this immediately
gave us just the same probabilistic
labeling as before we picked random
alphas and betas with this probability
and random elements and the fact that
this is some even or over some is
launched even over small potatoes what's
enough to serve us and then I suggested
homework that you should do this for for
sat you should do it with for linen with
right hand side minus one who did the
homework great you want an apple or you
want
well souls what's what's the dress up
yes yes you have to probe wise okay I on
the left side independently yes then I
took why on the right side okay this is
random uniform uniform uniform yeah yeah
and then I y prime minus X yes lifted
annoys me knew I / yeah with with your
wife yes and then you do it and it's not
you don't fall so the interns are still
there but they sure not be your friends
yeah and then it seemed easier because
the some that you get is just begin with
some offense where is empty as well yeah
you immediately get the summer fete
squared DX squared yeah but then you
have a minus 1 to the beta and then 1
minus 2 delta to the beta or something
right
you much I thought this is it most
something yeah it's evening I think it's
better man the next opponent is better
yeah this comes on what you put in front
yeah where your post ignore is eating so
the point is that the dangerous term
when these are the empty set have the
right sign a number moment and it's
actually a lot simpler so you just have
to to make sure that the empty set goes
your way and then you're done nobody
tried for sat okay so you want to report
something or I think much more in three
on the right sugar yeah but you cannot
so yes something a try and it doesn't
work is like you pick one and
independent of it so if it's if it's if
you picked it as one between 1-1 if you
put it as false then you can then you
can take the try to take the penalty and
if it's see pic you just true then you
take the noisy the stupid product
distribution on the 30 currants doesn't
work because you get the same kind of
yeah so have to pick a little right so
this is 3 depend that we can't take the
distribution yeah mmm yes you want some
noise on swing the question on minus
when the first one is true right you
don't want to pick when truly don't want
to pick pure parity but i must admit i
know this is easy but I didn't do my
homework i knows i can't do it i hope
that some of the students could go down
her but we tended I can okay if you're
interested I can do the homework in and
do it tomorrow you should get you know
chocolate your word Apple
what a good certain what we wanted to do
next is move tool so the point of this
exercise was to pull that's actually
easier when things get why do you have
more degrees of freedom and things are
better so what happens when you go the
other way and you go to two smaller
predicate is that you have less degrees
of freedom and when I sort of briefly
asked you know could you have a direct
piece of Peter and the point is that you
have two questions is you can't I said
before if you want to do this by the
free analysis you really want to
questions that uniform a random each on
their own and then there's very little
you can do if you have a uniformly
random question here in the uniform
around the question there because they
don't have anything to do with each
other you really need this three
questions to go somewhere but there's
one that you can get around it okay
and that's let's assume that pie here's
what I want to one mapping instead been
in fact you can compare a random
question here with the random question
there if it's sort of could get pie to
be a one one question right I mean the
problem here that all the things here
that projection to the same thing
they're they're sort of gives all the
correlations and stuff so does anybody
see any problems and having this 11 I
mean we didn't get it 11 the question
could be gested 11 yes you can't get
perfect completeness because then if you
have a label here you know what the
label is there and you can sort of go
back and forth so I don't know if I'm
going to get to this
so this is unique game conjecture
disaster for any epsilon you can have
completeness 1 minus epsilon some this
epsilon phi to be one to one and yeah l
equal to s of course please you have a
one-to-one mapping and but L of course
we'll have to depend on on epsilon so if
you decide on a certain tolerance for
the error there is a certain label size
so you can have these labels 121 in this
is taylor and this is the unique games
connect apple also didn't see it and
once you have unique games can get t you
can do lots and lots of things in
particularly gets a lot easier to work
with these predicates sore arity to but
for now I'll don't want to work with
those but I'll sort of want to do NP
completeness ok yeah we just don't
mention to be available even if you as
you knew g you just you for your
expansion will you write a problem you
just get product of two terms in pacha
Schwartz is not good enough so how do
you handle well now you're into it yeah
I have a possibility of course yeah it's
yes if you're going to do sort of one
question there and one question there
and you get into these majority
Stabler's kind of things right i mean
you can sort of do interesting things
you can at least have a random question
there and say something about the random
question there yeah i don't know if i
should devote last lecture to this has
it that's a unique case i usually some
i've changed my opinion of unique games
first you know it's so much fun to
assume unique games because you can
prove so many new things and then
suddenly it's people start doubting any
games and then you said well let's let's
program p completeness again and this
lecture series was supposed to be NP
completeness but we can we can see if we
get two unique games but at least that
sort of makes life a lot simpler in this
situation i want one because you can get
rid of these dependencies
the various bits project project onto
the same thing yeah so the thing I want
to discuss is what I started discussing
last time is sort of gadget and the
thing I ended with last time was sort of
a gadget reducing three sets to to sap
which had the property that i started
with 13 set closed and then i make 10 to
set closes in these three original
variables and one auxiliary variable
with the property that if this was
satisfied there was some value of a that
satisfied exactly seven well if this was
not satisfied to both that for all a you
know a true and false it's satisfied
with most six and then you just apply
this to each closing in a three set
formula with different values of a of
course x x y and z will be the original
guys with but one neway for each close
and then you could get a 55 / 56 and in
a proxima bility for max to set with
this number that's a function of seven
which is this number in 78 which is the
inapproximability for three cent and so
what I want to discuss today is you know
well how good the results can you get
from gadgets you know can you find the
best gadget is this gadget I presented
this is this the best gadget to go from
3 set 2 to set these kind of questions
so so this is not my results by the way
so most of what I going to say today's
is Travis on Sark in Sudan and whenever
so
let's try to be formal we take one
constraint of tea we make cake
constraints of Q of type Q and i want to
say so p okay thanks
and then I'll I might even assume way
two guys here
so now
so that is that you know tip similar
variables will sort of take care of the
fact that these are all sort of
different constraints if this condition
is full they will assume that the
maximum already the auxiliary variables
is some W and when this is false the
bestest w minus 1 and once you have
something like this and in the Proxima
bility 4p together with the value of W
will give us a minute proxim ability
result for Q right
and now you can say well this is your
stuff to ingenuity right that how would
you find the best gadget and this is a
people did it for 30 years because this
was sort of for 20 years at least but
let's think about this a little bit
I let's further provides to be concrete
let us think if this is real in and this
is to set suppose we had something that
looked like this
right so let's move mentally so we've
sort of made some we've started with the
question you know x 1 times X 2 times x
3 equal to 1 we made this into a number
of equations you know x1 times a1 is
equal to 1 x 1 x 8 3 is equal to minus 1
and so forth somehow and the way I want
to think about these is that lets at
each good assignment with peas except
like let's write down the values of a
that gives the witness this you know
that we can satisfy total weight W and
suppose this table looks like this we
had five variables so my question is now
did we need five variables 50 silver
variables yeah they're linearly the
police have enough they're going to curb
is this bad or
yes like a tree is all this one of these
good cases it seems like you're weird I
mean if you build a gadget and then you
fixate three two one yeah sounds like it
should still be you again yeah so this
is sort of saying that so a threesome is
one always
but the point is I could just cross it
out there so if you sort of look at the
two conditions this is 1 and this is 2
it doesn't hurt condition one right any
it because we still have the same
optimum if we fix it because that's what
we want it away three anyhow and the
point is can only help into because we
go get less freedom in these cases there
are less possibilities for the axillary
variables so we can only get better
sound and sort of in the reduction okay
so who said well you've already got an
apple but we had I had I heard heard
other good comment sort of what by
linear what's the independence why is
this because you can replace it let's
say here I've 81 quad- a plug-in good
he'll also have a fun say the same to
you so they thought suppose a 5 is equal
to a1 times a2 that's what you're saying
it's linear so so what you throw away he
stood when that will create an equation
with three variables I'm trying to make
the student yes I mean these linear
dependencies between a1 and a2 that this
you can do right and what much is a very
can of course replace yeah so if a1 is
equal to plus minus i2 unless you insist
off the right side being right hand side
p minus 1 or something like no I'm not
right you're not I'm dum dum doing
chillin which is are you doing tooling
you're not into that well even yep good
if I'm doing so we did that matter that
was doing to third no no because I have
negation for free also there right ya
see it
so suppose a 2 is equal to minus a 1
ayah that came that whenever a to appear
serology replace it by minus a 1 or you
know in the to set notation a one
compliment which again will have the
property that you know since they are
each other's negation in the positive
cational for 1 i'm doing equally well
and i'm only restricting the power of
the of the sort of bad guy into I mean
it's easier to prove sounds because I
have less cases so she noticed 8 a 5 in
a 40 to each other's negation so I can
get rid of it at five I want to get
through the way three I go through the
way to you know a four a five a good
minus a 4 and a 1 I did Martin hey one
yeah everyone is asleep what even is the
same as extreme yes a 163 is that bad or
can we replace the ones over by the
private can you f replace oxalate
variables by primary variables
my word put was it so that we only have
I for okay so this means in this case
how many auxiliary variables do we have
four or four primary variables moving
for Constance
right or or equal I took silver I wanted
always took the same battery we don't
care either how many do we have how many
axilla variables could you possibly need
them to the number of satisfying
assignments and you get rid of the old
ones all minus ones and the other than
assignments so first of all we have
negation from free right yeah so that
sort of gives a vision right that's one
and then we sort of get rid of the
constant and then we get rid of the
three primary variables it's four so we
only need four axillary variables okay
so that's a good start right that sort
of means that we have a finite objected
at our hands which was not completely
obvious to start with
virus need to do this
so this idea before
I don't think so yeah yeah that's why I
like it it's nice and simple right now I
think that was new light I don't yeah it
sort of once you sit down and think
about it instead of sort of playing
around with all these things it's really
touchy all you should do these things so
we have three primary variables and we
have four auxiliary ones
alright so this means we have we have
seven choose to which is what 21
left-hand sides we have two right-hand
side streets you know they can be plus
minus one and we have seven equations
we're allowing up instead of not obvious
when I allow an equation like x equal to
1 but then I'm going to think of this as
a tool in conditional salt okay it's not
neat if I somehow you have to check that
when you replacing things here you're
replacing something by its negation but
then wasn't want to get rid of constants
so that means if I had something with
depend on to where I was and now get
something that depends on one variables
i have to allow one variable things to
appear oh okay and 22 right hand side
for these so this is 42 plus 14
so this means i have 56 possible
equation so i say that we do now wait so
now let's just try to look at what kind
of waste or do i need so we have suggest
introduce a variable for the weight of
equation hi WI
it's unnecessary because as long as you
could not collapse yes yeah yeah and so
we could allow repetitions and so forth
right it's not gonna find it yeah no
yeah so we're Italy I didn't really tell
you but I said I had a weighted version
to start with right we were good and not
now we add you know we collapse things
and add up the weights and we have
selected 1 and 2 are just linear
inequalities that was right
and
oh yeah I kind of see it for two because
you just put for every if you give me
the excess I just put down for
everything i can say a and then your
inequality but the extension quantifier
is bothers me yes right on top of it but
so they existential you can drag one for
each possibility
it's an excellent point okay so the
point is on top of it I know for each
assignment what this accelerator will
should take that's what what defines the
identity of an auxiliary variable right
so i know that you know for the first
satisfying assignment a one should take
this value that's how I define subjects
already right this is the table I had so
we said these particular values should
in fact given the weight W and all other
value should give it most w because I
don't want to i want to turn up to be on
target but the particular values that
define hook similar variables should
give w so that's actually linear
equality for this value and inequality
that you don't be w anywhere else that's
a good point thanks you want to chop it
yes
everybody happy
so now we just write it you know we
computer scientist afterward we have a
linear program and we just solve it I
mean we have even have it just at 56
variables and you know we have eight
different values for each of these
assignments to to do when we write down
and pee and then we run it and then we
get something well let me draw it shred
them so there's a nice way to draw this
get that you get
so you take the three-dimensional cube
yeah
and on alleges inequality
Kurt
and in fact I'm sort of cheating here so
I claim now I have one two three four
five silver variables but this to think
there is diagonal if you want it's the
constant one so have some equations of
weight one and then I am this is the
gadget to cut themselves let's drop the
more gadget first research to do so only
this ability of minimizing w yeah you
need to admit yeah you mean minimizing w
right fun you think this is the best
this is the best data to reduce three
lengths to where what did I say I was
going to reduce soon what what it do
cycle yeah but I meant to Liam
everything applies so the two that way i
can write down the two subjects in a
moment but this is the thrill into
tuning judge sorry diagonals main
diagonals so you're not going on the
cross
so this sort of shows that it's hard to
aprox tooling within 11 / 12 plus
epsilon 40 40 laps okay
and where is that was good god should we
check this and we talking about the
question so we have 16 equations and in
the good case you can satisfy 12 and in
the bad case you can only satisfy them
what we can we can be happy to do this
so if X 1 times X 2 10 6 30 is equal to
1 we can satisfy 12 equations ok this is
checking ok so now you have to make sure
so this means if we can do 1 minus
epsilon m in the beginning we get 12am
Tanner and if we can just do half plus
epsilon hope you get
and sorry sorry should be 20 right in
the good case we get 12 in the bad case
we have only 10 so then reason for 11 is
sort of the average between 10 and 12
and we started with a half right good I
am so we can also do to set I'm not sure
if I
yes
ok
so in fact you can do 11 verses I don't
you want to see this gadget so three set
this is three linked to Tucson do you
want to see that pebbles to see it yeah
we're 18 is it a nice picture No
sort of symmetric put
pull
let's talk to my goodness okay
so good so then yes sorry yes is it any
good okay am I mean I twice not very fun
and yes this keeps first please sr i was
going to save this case 21 or 22 yes you
can get the max cut cut that also okay
so what's the problem in getting a max
cut gadget very we don't have negations
okay and on top of it we actually have
to look it started if you're going to
reduce your parents it's actually
without abnegation also on the starting
side so we need to look separately at
equations X plus X Y Z equal to 1 and X
Y Z equal to minus 1 I me to have to
make gadgets for both of them so it gets
a little more complicated but you can
get max capitals is it does it give you
the best
it gives you 16 / 17 okay then that's
the best angle so now we want to do
better and now and as far as i know
these three constants ideas presented
you are the bestest known with the NP
completeness well if you assume unique
games you can do better yes when they
were done in this t SS w paper no
questions but these guys just did they
exist no no they they were they found
them so they're very low your catches
for reductions between these problems
and they improve yeah well not all of
them but some of the mix it faces the
three central to that cat that I I gave
you last time existed before but there
is a better one that they found for that
reduction so now we want to do better
right we want to beat these numbers I
want to tell you some ideas how one
could possibly go about picking these
numbers and someone no don't work and
some I don't know whether they work or
not and we're sort of that let's discuss
the idea so maybe you can come up with
some some angle on something that's
better yeah so this this is only for CSP
three yes does this is any of this
machinery booty
something so what but I really am just
looking at there is your example vertex
number can you claim the same sense is
the best you can get by engagement um
but that so many things ESP but not
exactly it's not really yes this yes
there will be don't accelerate variables
and gadgets really right we really have
a big reduction from a proof with
certain properties to yeah so it's a
different game okay so so let's see
which any ideas what come up how we're
going to do better I just said you know
we'll take three lane and we'll find
optimal gadgets and will you can start
from something else and so what should
we start from us but then these games is
cheating I already told you this right
so we started something with no it's NP
hard well I've proved two problems hard
right so let's and the thing I proved
243 linen 3sat and I in fact work harder
to do with reset to get perfect
completeness that's true but maybe we
should start with reset could this
possibly work not for toxic situation
why because we already gorgeous
yeah so this is question how do these
compose right right so the point is
you're you're right and so really the
reason was a simple the only one gave a
presentation together yeah so the point
is that so one thing is mysterious to me
though that that so you're starting from
the long coat and the long coat is the
longest cold you can create so if you
are creating like let's say you are
checking the long coat with three lin
brown and then you put that gadget on
top of that hmm so can't you just
emulated by just doing the long coat
immediate leave it out like any again
two steps yeah yeah yeah sure yeah
that's one thing okay but can you do
better with gadgets I mean is there like
any situation when like if you put
gadgets on top of this non-core checking
you look at hand wrong then we don't
know you do too sexy big monster I told
you
so what okay silly very open-ended 30
cause it's not something that's a very
very bits are not part of any wrongful
they are part of the on the edges of the
long how they combine something like
that no because each channel code is
only for one side now we've combined
both sides now so let's let happen yes
I'm there to check it's an excellent
channel and I have things to say so long
so this is all the direct PCP type of
thing right now you're sort of saying we
have the wrong code what could we
possibly doing another you sort of have
a different starting point so the only
thing I wanted I won't talk about this
first and I want to talk about this so
foot but that the only thing I would say
so far about the second point is that
3sat is no good because we had is in
this condition from three linked to
three said that I showed the first
lecture which in fact have no maxillary
variables so in fact whatever we do to
three sides we can just do a two-step
reduction we do equally well from three
months so it will never pay to go to
three set but let's take Mario
suggestion and in fact look at this in
front of but we have the long code what
possibly could be bad and that's what
you're saying right we had all the
functions ransom
sounds is saying some of you are
combining two players although yeah i'm
at course there is this i have our
favorite picture we have you know a few
here we have GW here we when we did
three leave a sort of
hmm
so this is something that I was thinking
a long time ago so let's let's think
about it okay right behind our label
cover we had the functions that we know
well and the parotid test and now we
sort of on top of this parity test we
sort of we add gadget so what do we do
well we sort of we now look at the
person like this a little bit right soon
so see if I can drive this message home
so whenever we sort of forget when these
come from these allow your variables in
in those unscrupulous provers try and
talk to my stings and then we make a
reduction in particular will introduce
some auxiliary variables but we know
what these external variables should
look like in the good case alright then
we have a satisfying assignment we know
that the value of this exceed linear
variable should in fact be Princeton's
the end of these two variables
so
the postman and we know that the origins
of these two guys is in fact a few of X
and eat the GW one
Oh
and
my point is instead of making this sort
of dented forever we know what it should
look like we know that if we form a
different string of length the big
length by doing the corresponding
operation here this very bit that the
word exists in our proof should in fact
take exactly the value of the axillary
variable all right
as opposed the question sort of
and these persons can only help us yeah
this can only help us because we're sort
of using more information before we had
the auxiliary variables with actually
produce different I mean could be used
completely different in the different
conditions but now we sort of realize
that we can reuse these guys okay and I
thought this was a great idea but it
doesn't work okay so let's try to
analyze a little bit why it doesn't work
what do you mean it doesn't work it
still gives us yeah it keeps the same it
keeps exactly the same bound that we go
through the gadget of course it can't be
worse since we're reusing things that we
before analyzed that are independent but
it doesn't work okay so what's the
problem in trying to hook this so now I
said when you're always thinking about
such protocols we should think ourself
as as unscrupulous proved ER and now
with well this should be so what is this
really done it down to the distribution
of the constraint or they do not good so
now you have instead of this one's in
the distribution you have a combination
of but this is just a string of my Z
prime belongs to L right but as you're
probably about to say it doesn't have
the uniform distribution okay in fact it
because this is random but this you know
first of all the bits are three-quarters
serum or false but on top of it whenever
this is false everything that projects
onto that business phones
so it lives on minus 1 month ago so the
second second thing is the real proposal
by the first you could just take mins
yeah if it has a very different
disability lift that it's reading from a
different table because now instead of
reading with the uniform distribution
we're reading with some distribution
which is really I mean has support on a
completely different sets it's really so
if you're thinking about progress that's
doing on top of it if I tell somebody
you know fact is if you think of this as
one right enough to prove the fact I
going to look for this sort of means
whenever I'm going to look at this I
know the value of x so the protocol
really changes now and so when you have
to analyze this you can't really sort of
analyze it should be primal you can't
really think of this as analyzing doing
this by the Fourier transform because
this has a completely different flavor
where is this unscrupulous prove already
sort of see pratis see we completely to
the f table then you actually when it
has to do this for c prime e really
already knows the value for x so you can
sort of think well what did I right here
for this value of x and in fact has
partial information about the why
because whenever this is true we can
read off the value of y and when this
was false it doesn't know any
information such as partial information
on why so you can sort of get partial
information of this and you get into
lots of interesting questions to try to
understand boolean functions when you
sort of a probabilistic information on
the inputs so this intermediate
questions ease raises lots and lots of
interesting questions you know if you
have probabilistic information of why
and you have some
deterministic question of X and you know
you're going to compare one of these two
when you're sort of have a bad thing
game which value should you take and so
forth and I try this a lot and I
couldn't make this flight but you get
into lots of interesting question about
boolean functions so that's why one way
i reproach that i felt i tried a la
tempête he'll retire you know it's not
that i wrote down that this doesn't work
but it sort of says that it could be
this intermediate distributions that
someone can be used sure to get some
concept I mean some optimal constant
which is not which is not going to be
match with the unique the constant you
get from the unique game right or is it
clear that by for instance mark scott
will never be able to even if you wella
so that would prove somehow I sum up
starting with this label cover and only
doing this like this we're never gonna
get the gamma some brilliant constant
for four children to that I think is
true yeah but I couldn't make this
let me I have two more said hello am i
doing am so let me just take a few more
things I want to say now we can talk
okay
Oh
so something i didn't use throughout
this den de traduction I don't think p
ssw were aware of is that in fact if you
look at the proof we actually have more
than i was using just before we know
when the good case of thrilling we
always have a satisfying assignment on
top of it all the for satisfying
assignments will appear equally often in
this and son and also in the bad case
all eight this will appear equally often
it's not like we are satisfied para to
have the time that all day eight
assignments are equally frequent okay
this is what i call uselessness parrot
is useless so Perry predicate is useless
if you can't distinguish the cases when
you can almost over satisfied from the
case when you get the one most uniform
distribution on cubed strings what next
it's useless why this happening makes it
easy and well I in the pit in the paper
where we prove this I said that p is
useful for Q if I promise you can almost
always satisfied few then you can do
something non trivial for Q okay and the
predicate is useless if you can't do
anything useful for any Q and that
property turns out to be equivalent with
this uniform so that's why
so since the case
so using that fact this is a gadget for
three set for four to set from three
live
so if you have x times y times e is
equal to 1
sorry so here you can sense i will just
yeah well you can set aside to closes
but you can do three if both x and y are
true because then you can set a 12 crew
/ z is true because then you can set a
12 too true well if these are both look
through you can set they want to false
and if this is true you can say they
want and you satisfy or three and then
you just check well if the parity of
this is one these things would never
happen at the same time because you know
true is minus one so it can't be that
all three or minus one so these two
cases intersect nicely by four random
string they're sort of independent and
if you work it out you actually get 21 /
22 words with this simpler get it you
can is this you're happy with this I'm
before I had very strong conditions
right that if you had a for each
satisfying assignment for the new
satisfy the predicate you would do well
and but for each bone cells 500 you
would do less well and in fact I chain
that all what I need is the appropriate
if you were in the case of a random good
assignment you should have something
good and if a random assignment overall
you show two words and then you can that
actually does for much simpler get this
because that's because how you the
instance you obtain your type of yeah of
checking off alone yeah that's because
you look deep into the proof and I
didn't only proved in the probability
result i proved the stronger profit okay
but it doesn't help you know you don't
get better results from 92 shot or two
lien by this you get smaller gadgets
particular plaintiff of the same quality
it is clear up this is no it's just
that's the way it is
but if you formalize the ideas we hear
it it's in something just helping us to
get rid of the symmetric parts right
yeah so the problem that's happening
sort of is that these the big guy just
take care of all the symmetries and now
the symmetries move over to the to the
assignment parts and some of you get
smaller gadgets but not too much
happened so yeah so now the question
what were you so you want to start with
something better so yeah just another so
could you sort of trying to actually say
that they formally don't do better so
you take an assignment that assumes the
symmetry but you scimitar eyes and you
yes here so when you're looking at these
symmetric things you this is just an LP
or also as far as I remember and yeah
the symmetric thing is still in ll I
mean when you take taking these sums
instead it's a symmetrical p I mean
still another piece you can check that
together together optimal that you can't
to burn
so but really let's have another
starting point so then because it's what
other starting points would be happy
sure that sounds good in the proximal
military South you know three lane was
the champion so far coming possibly hope
for a better starting point yes
presently non-binary yes I didn't really
try not but there's no reason that we
couldn't start with the non binary
predicate and build something on gadget
on topic that's completely possible yes
so if you if you do go for maximum 22
matalan q4 poor friend well in fact em
if that matters doesn't have to be
primed you in the proximal military
success improve it's basically the same
proof okay but this is actually good
starting point so let's see to find an
optimal gadget from this THU to sat
well so let's look more closely at let's
find an optimal value from the sir ma'am
let's look a little bit more closely to
the linear program I creating how many
in ciliary variables did we have yeah
if they had a number of satisfying
assignments I sort of got to to the
number of satisfying assignments okay
and
right
what what do you do with the witness no
longer will you yeah Pam the question is
what to do with them you could use a
code then you have yeah okay yeah maybe
this maybe was a bad time let's follow a
different time okay just you could we
just subtracted them for so we didn't
need to subscribe if you are absolutely
variable Z and I know but you'll have
your neighbors constraints today just
use the digital binary for you yeah why
do you mean well because you it depends
on what your time for this if your type
of it is too yeah so the cash for it is
that's right it we sort of the original
variables are not mod Q right and I want
to stick them into a tooling too and
it's sort of how do we go down again it
is not really defined when we have
different domains so yeah it's clear
that something but let's let's I sort of
pick this up on the Flies which was a
bad idea that has a different predators
in mind in fact just offering 60 we
should look for sparse predicates right
this parcel predicate it seems that more
powerful they are we on sports
predicates with very good dinner
probability factors
this costume in the number of side
effects items yeah the number of things
at the set and let me if you wanted this
workshop two weeks ago action have a
very nice new predicate to work with
so what he did one of the things it does
is that he has a certain era podium
predicate with eight satisfying
assignment which is in fact useless with
my definition of users so let's see what
this predicate looks like
so this is in fact just a linear code
dimension 3 if you put it that way
another way to say it's that sort of
data mart code
so really it's just a linear space of
dimension 3 and sort of the the only one
with not repeated coordinates if you
wanted sort of the has a modern coding
it's sort of the value of all non
trivial linear functions on each of
eight inputs but this is three
definitions basically saying the same
thing you can you see this
so if you label the coordinates by the
linear functions and
the code words are put it
alright this is corresponding to 1 1 1
the square root 1 minus 11 these are the
code word corresponding puts these are
the linear functions and this is what
other Federation's so this coordinate is
always the X or distal coordinates
that's a new fresh fit so then this is
the extra this and this this is the X or
addition this and this and this is the
actual to these three corners that's
different so you get 18 puts on seven
bits each and this is a linear space and
so forth so they satisfy the assignments
of you know function yeah what they eat
no I mean the coordinate sorry I love
you I mean sorta will do all right but I
think of the coordinates is given by the
non trivial linear functions sometimes
it makes sense to have a constant bit
also and the correct evaluations you
know if this is this an evaluation of
all the linear functions on some input
but you could take the dual view right I
view this as he you know it's a damned
odd code by take away the 10 goddamn our
code of something is too valuable in
your functions on this input subspace
minus the zeros yeah if you want we can
add sometimes it's been reasoning about
these things we can add a coordinate
here that's all one in all the vectors
put that photo and then it's really the
full Hadamard code over each dimples so
this turns out to be you know useless
it's hard to tell if you can sense our
constraints of this phone from when you
can do a random seven bit string
hope youse yeah so what based is useful
for gadgets ok so now we'll be trying to
investigate it as I sort of just hand
waved my way through this good
constructions that we have only
financial manually variables you know we
have only so many constraints we have an
LP we solve it so let's look a little
more carefully how what the LP actually
looks like
Oh
right see if you if you look at number
of syllabary variables then in fact it
was total number of satisfying
assignments minus one minus number of
primary variables that we had minus 1
this is the constant V also okay which
in our case is 120 1-8 which is 120 so
if we're thinking about going to tool in
then we have roughly a hundred and
twenty choose 2 times 2 which is you
know 144,000 wait
which is still manageable but we have
like 2 to the 120 constraints because we
wanted something to be true for all
auxiliary variables right for all
assignments to exhilarate variables so
this LP turns out to be difficult to run
okay so the point is now i don't know if
you can make a better gadget from these
predicates to toulon or not
yep
so huge just the consumer feeling
yeah you can sort of types have some
separation Oracle or go to the duel what
the well it's not bad not good but yeah
yeah thats its notice but you can't just
take your ELP off the shelves over and
do this no no this has been I was trying
to convince my graduate students to do
this for a while but they would not ok
so I'll tell you a little bit so I've
played with this for a while
so always when you cancel the program
you can always look at the different
problem so it is that is I've sort of
done max tooling to Safari right i mean
try to satisfy as many questions as
possible and then you could get 11 or 10
but let's do mean to try to minimize the
number of false a questions instead and
and since of course it's very related to
mike student to i can just look at the
reduction is Hatford for the
reducibility of max tooling to and that
actually gives 5 over 4 and this was
sort of the best constant known for a
long time okay
so if we call this h7 this predicate you
know this is H 2 to the K minus 1 in
general for general k so h7 is the seven
dimensional thing and of course you can
generalize it down there chance yourself
it applies to all these things then in
fact you can get 11 / 18 by gadget from
this child prodigy so you know this
turns out to be incredibly symmetric and
I wrote down a gadget that actually
gives you a lemon / 8 and checked with
my computer yes is there any other state
it could its if you assume unique games
is hard to approximate within a constant
so but now when you're sort of thinking
going to what Mario said is it
completely impossible that you know you
should get the gamma some brilliant some
constant on these things well it could
be quite possible that you have an
infinite family here a very hard
constraint satisfaction problem and then
family of gadgets that actually tends to
a very strange number know that
everything seems to be rational here I
mean how are you going to get the
government slaves you could just get a
sequence oceanography but the spotters
are you might get the girl man swilley
on some perhaps but you cannot get the
unique game I mean the uni game is just
yet another approximation problem and if
you could get the unique game then you
will have proven the NP hardness of uni
game alright so what's all with us sorry
what's wrong and it's nothing wrong with
that but yeah I don't know what's wrong
with that
so the challenge now is it to understand
you know now we're back to the 70s here
that we actually have to understand
these gadgets by hand or by you know
being a very clever programmer okay so i
will be interested to see if anybody's
you know willing to program here to try
to figure out the optimal reduction from
this gadget from this thing to either to
Lenore to cytomax cut and it's not
completely out of the question even
though it's non-trivial actually there
could be something wrong with I'm sorry
I just answering there could be
something wrong like that because there
is this new result that you can do the
unique game actually faster than to the
end I and if you could do it with budget
reduction the these would contradict to
the exponential time hypothesis so well
visit but then that's a very good point
which I haven't really keep track of
like that yeah I'm just talking now
polynomial size and I have arbitrary
constants and the question is if you
would assume that three-set you suppose
want to assume the exponential time
hypothesis right then if you sort of
look then it's very difficult to die i
have always gotten this you know I've
used a pair of repetition and the
parallettes slice of the parallel
repetition has been n to the K where
this K is sort of related to the sound
as I want so will there is sometimes
described as very very you know the two
to the square doesn't rule out the two
to the square root n algorithm for for
approximating say max really but then
you have to use other results either
starting pcps not apply the parallel
repetition where you don't get the
blow-up you can sort of get label
caliber you don't get the blow up the
depends on epsilon like most cookies
shrugs so then you have to start keeping
track of how does the polynomial blow up
to and you don't want to big blow up as
I'm paying with the parallel repetition
so here is nothing really exclude I mean
a huge polynomial blow-ups all over the
place I'm not doing so well
and I'm not really sure what to do next
one thing I was going to do is maybe try
to to prove this result by chunk that
this is our impact simulation resistant
or we could but fine minutes I don't
think it actually makes sense to really
set it up but then I'll Allah start
doing that tomorrow in such a case if
there are any more questions so doesn't
the LPI was ultimately yes because you
isn't he essentially picking rows of the
whole the whole truth table or
television I can pick these videos and
you have all combinations of vectors
yeah yes it's you can think you know is
and so you can think you know you maybe
don't need to discount it for instance
uses of all auxiliary variables oh yeah
and it does use it also the uselessness
it doesn't it's not the strict editing
sense it uses to uselessness but you
could suddenly if you advance you're
using the uses and maybe you don't I
mean maybe you could make a blessing
metric gadget and this is doesn't use
everything if you got it and use a
little bit more of the uselessness but
sure there are lots of symmetries here
right so you could hope to get by with
much fewer variables but you if you're
going to write down and honest when do
some LP prove where you really have to
make this thumb very much and then
otherwise you need to know some of these
implicit things yeah so now you think
you too if you just want to beat the 11
/ 12 we can note that this this
predicate implies lots of parities right
the XOR of the first three bits is one
there are lots of other ex horse so you
can use you have lots of parity gadget
sitting in there you can just take a
parity gadget and that will actually
give you equally well so it's clear that
you're going to get 11 / 12 for max tool
in here and you can even make a very
symmetric point and you can ask is this
local optimum for this linear program or
can we do so steepest ascent from there
and I wasn't able but I didn't try
myself there but I wasn't able to
convince somebody else is the good
company it is I companies even worse
than I mean it's a work this is at least
you know many hours of work but maybe
that's and i'll stop here and then
clicking you tomorrow